have you ever pitched to one of the
studios yep there's no one of the the
indie Studios once a particular script I
mean I mean I pitched to them but this
one particular indie studio this
producer I was brought into meeting to
pitch with him and I was brought in by
another producer who's a woman and she's
come meet this guy will pitch him this
movie so I came in I pitched him the
movie and it was a romantic comedy and
the male character the lead character he
starts out with one girlfriend he breaks
up with her he ends up with another
girlfriend by the end of the movie and
the reason I bring that up is because to
pitch it this guy this executive he says
so is this what your life is like I said
what do you mean he goes well this guy
he's got all these women in your movie
he's got all these women what the hell
is going on I go well he has one
girlfriend that he gets another one I
don't think that's that's really a lot
he goes I know it sounds like a lot to
me that's like you know so he seems like
a womanizer that's what he seems like
I'm like okay I said no why that's this
aggro was coming at me but I'm like it's
a it's just a weird meeting anyway so we
leave and the and the woman producer
that I came with she goes I apologize I
go what's going on she goes well I've
been dating him and he wants to be
exclusive and I don't want to be
exclusive so so all this guy was doing
was sounding off at me as a way of
telling her you know you're you know why
won't you dip why won't you be exclusive
to me you know that's really what the
minute was about you know so that was
the weirdest pitch meeting ever because
nothing to do with me you know and
sometimes it's out of your control what
can you do you just do your job
pitch pitch pitch smile do your job and
that's it at least she was there to tell
you that because you wouldn't have known
otherwise yeah you would have thought it
was you yeah and I was not dating her by
the way but at least someone was there
because so many times things like that
happen and there's an answer for it
we'll never know but at least you got to
know that so then when you went in to do
other things was that experience always
up there because you knew maybe it's
totally not about me but I don't have
they're telling me the story as to why
someone's acting this way yeah one of
the first I did I came in with
actually a pretty famous writer we've
written something together and we were
pitching at Paramount
and as we're pitching he's he was
talking he was he we had this long super
complicated really detailed pitch that
we thought was wonderful and he was
describing it and as that's we're
pitching as we're telling the story the
guy this executive starts to do this he
starts to do anyway and after a while we
realized we're putting him to sleep and
you know we're comedy writers so we
stopped and he started talking about it
but it was like what a note to get
you're putting me to sleep
yeah we actually literally this guy and
so that was like a huge lesson for us we
learned keep the pitch or don't go into
all these freaking beat tales you know
so and never forget that one yeah well
there was no note behind the note I knew
what was going on with that one okay
indeed